I bear with me on this is this kind of
egotistical to say that this takes place
in the Harry Potter universe because
that would imply Harry Potter owns the
universe and it is badass kid but it
doesn't I know this perplexes me
fantastic beasts and where to find them
two fantastic beasts and where to find
them is a new adventure that takes place
in the universe that Harry Potter takes
place in this takes place I believe it's
70 years before the events of Harry
Potter and it takes place in America so
that's that's different that means new
set of rules new terminology instead of
muggles I call them no match no magic
make sense and the gist of this story is
a British wizard comes to America played
by Eddie Redmayne his name is Newt
Scamander I thought it was Newt
Scamander for the longest time so I feel
like I should share with you that's not
what it is and basically he has a
briefcase it's full of these fantastic
beasts and this muggle or Nomad opens up
the case and these beasts get out so now
they've got to find him there's other
things bobbing and weaving and there
Colin Farrell he plays a wizard is it
good is he bad is he kind of a dick
pointed it's a new adventure in Harry
Potter world the name of Harry Potter is
gonna sell his movie even though it's
nowhere in the title this is an
enjoyable film first of all Eddie
redmayne's character Newt Scamander I
liked him I just did there's a love that
this guy has for animals and these
fantastic beasts other people might
consider them monsters but he loves them
and he wants to understand them we must
nurture them back to hell he's pretty
much an animal rehabilitator for magical
creatures that he then sets back into
the while he's like a zookeeper really
loves the zoo animals and I love the
gnome edge the muggle friend I thought
he was great there was a sweetness to
this pair that is something that you
remember seeing in the original Harry
Potter franchise and it being a new
thing I know on one hand you probably
shouldn't compare it to the Harry Potter
movies or the Harry Potter books or
story on the other hand it is in the
same universe and you just can't help it
and the movie is sweet but sometimes
it's on the fringe lines like oh is it
sweet or is it kind of sappy and cheesy
yeah goes there too basically this is
how I can break it down it has Harry
Potter esque magic in this world but the
world itself is the muggle world there's
not a flaw just addressing if I want to
address a flaw I will address some of
the paceline some of the phasic in this
movie yeah it doesn't always flow
sometimes the movie wants to
there and then jumps there and then hey
downtime alright let's get back to the
fantastic be stuff just get back to it
now yeah some of the pacing was off it
really shows in the fact that this movie
wraps up for about twenty minutes yet
Return of the King ending with no
trilogy backing it up I really felt like
fantastic beast for a large chunk of it
there's this chunk of time it's just
it's a showcase of the magic of the
world and it is neat and it's
interesting to see and I buy into it
because I love the Harry Potter buck but
in the end a showcase doesn't make for a
smooth cinematic ride Colin Farrell I
thought was great you don't see a lot of
him but when he does shine he shines
I'll say he's a standout in this one for
sure and what this movie does and I feel
like this is the point of it it sets up
its own franchise I they said they want
to make what five of these films or
something like that yeah this definitely
sets up things to cozy alright ade stay
tuned for the next one in the end
fantastic beasts and where to find them
was sweet it was enjoyable I enjoyed it
I had a good time it's a good family
time at the cinema Eddie redmayne's a
standout the villainous element is a bit
shaky I'm like I don't it didn't really
work for me
that might just be me I will say
fantastic beasts and where to find them
is a good time no alcohol required and
this video is brought to you by loot
crate this month's theme is magic very
fitting that I'm putting it on this
video it would make sense so you can
follow the link below with promo code
Jeremy Jones to save yourself 10% on
November's loot crate you have until the
19th to get it otherwise you'll lose it
forever so no pressure but time is of
the essence I'm just saying so fantastic
beasts and where to find them have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more